season one of House of the Dragon is
almost as good and if not just as good
as the first four seasons of Game of
Thrones that's a very high combination
to pin onto the show but I think it's
leaning more towards the almost as good
since there was a couple aspects holding
the season back from Perfection firstly
let's go into the glaring positives and
talk about the plot of the Season House
of the Dragon is in a weird spot where
the meat of the stories later on and
right now they primarily have to do a
ton of setup most shows given the same
task would be pretty terrible since
they'd be overly expository driven and
the plot wouldn't be engaging enough to
enthrall the audience but here in House
of the Dragon they somehow make the
story riveting throughout every episode
despite the limitations of the story not
being as Grand or crazy as Game of
Thrones they do this by having a
consistent presence of entertaining
conflict that simultaneously explores
the intricacies of every character we
don't just sit here and have someone
tell us the histories of House Targaryen
or house Hightower and instead said we
witnessed the rich characters work to
overcome heaps of obstacles that
simultaneously builds them into concrete
characters with fully established traits
and personalities even Side characters
like rhaenys and Corliss are incredibly
detailed and scenes in which we explore
their complex motivations like corliss's
quest for power and rainy's love for our
family are entrancing this is
essentially catalyzed by the debacle of
wanting to get entangled in Royal
politics so the conflict works for both
interesting story progression and
character progression each episode has a
micro problem that needs to be solved
and that's something that a lot of shows
forget normally most time and attention
is spent on the macro problems but here
the emphasis is put on the small
conflicts that develop characters for
other shows these minor obstacles
generally act as filler however that
isn't the case here whether that's
renera overcoming the responsibilities
of marriage childbirth loss or love the
writers essentially send every character
down an insane obstacle course of
conflict that sets them up for the
oncoming war that on its own is pretty
impressive from our writing standpoint
but what makes this even crazier to
grasp is having so many scenes with an
ensemble of main characters interacting
with one another this is something that
David and Dan really dropped the ball on
for how underdeveloped and awkward their
group scenes were in the later Seasons
but the writers in this show handle it
very well whether that's the Last Supper
the funeral of Lena the wedding dinner
or any small Council scene the attention
to detail and thought that's put into
every microscopic character beat floors
me and the characters get to shine
brightly the coverage always accounts
for small character reactions that act
as development for them that doesn't
require dialogue like the entire post
funeral scene where every character is
glaring at one another and just from
their expressions alone you can easily
tell their views of one another the
Ensemble scenes are always a joy to
watch and it never feels like the
writers are leaving out any important
interactions like when you think about
it in Game of Thrones season 8 why did
Arya never have a scene with Daenerys
given that she idolized the independent
and badass nature of her ancestors or
even character pairings that last less
than a minute and needed much more time
before cutting away House of the Dragon
never feels like they are missing out on
development and every character
interaction moment is fully realized we
aren't getting thrown out of scenes
jarringly like Jon Snow being on the
verge of telling his sisters his
identity and instead we have a complete
beginning middle and end for each scene
none of that [ __ ] lazy writing from
season 8 is here and it's refreshing
that the writers are competent at
writing long and fully fleshed out
dialogue scenes which on the subject of
dialogue it's pretty good here now it
isn't as outstanding as it is in Game of
Thrones given that it's pulled directly
from George R Martin but I think the
writers still did a great job in House
of the Dragon I'm honestly surprised and
did not have high hopes for the dialogue
going into the show since the source
material doesn't really have any to draw
from and they still manage to make some
quotable lines that still stick with me
after finishing the season I'm will not
sit here and suffer crows that come to
Feast on their Corpses
to be suffocated by all this [ __ ]
polity King what is this
breed does not remember blood and
remembers names she could have her
answer now stuffed in her father's mouth
along with his withered [ __ ] let's end
this Mama's Farm
so even though the dialogue isn't
technically as good as Game of Thrones
that doesn't mean it's not great because
Game of Thrones level dialogue is a very
hard bar to clear on its own overall for
the story it was still able to be
entertaining without relying on any
major twists to throw the narrative into
the stratosphere especially since each
episode had some form of major
confrontation going on that always kept
the audience engaged with what was
happening with every character because
of this no episode felt underwhelming
and the show felt really consistent in
terms of strength of the plots
looking at the characters I think we
have an amazing roster here to me the
standout is definitely viserys Targaryen
The Way his character balance is wanting
to keep things peaceful while not
wanting to overly address conflict is an
endearingly wholesome quality despite it
not being a very good trait for a king
since he's such a pure-hearted character
it's a tragedy that he meets such an
agonizing and slow death this
transformation is so jaw-dropping and
the ability to visually track his Decay
throughout the season was a great idea
from the writers parody considine
seamlessly Blends between these points
of taking on increasingly more pain and
taking on the burden of trying to hide
it and appear stronger I love the small
detail starting out where you can subtly
see he's hurting on the inside but he
doesn't want to show it that
meticulously planned out acting and
focusing on the intricacies is
Brilliance and seeing it progress
towards a later and more Grievous stages
of his death was outstanding what I
think is single-handedly the best moment
in the show is visir smiling at the Last
Supper and witnessing his family be
happy for one last time time it makes me
cry thinking that he died a happy man
and this was a last drop of pure joy he
could witness in his sea of misery every
scene with viserys was great and I'm
rooting for Patty Constantine to get an
Emmy win the next standout character is
definitely Damon it's kind of hard to
describe the man he's cunning smart
Suave sexy unpredictable Brave and
lovesick at his hands dirty he's kind of
the likable Wild Card of the group and
because of that it makes him so
intriguing not to mention that Matt
Smith is pretty goaded and it feels like
he slips right into the character
Otto Hightower is just an absolute babe
and you can't dispute that reesephon and
his hypnotizing gravelly voice made
every line he spoke so varied and
detailed I played a montage of him
saying Your Grace in a prior review so I
feel like I should play that again here
what must I say in general Your Grace
Your Grace Your Grace I'm sorry your
grace that's hardly how I viewed it your
grace
will you honor me you're great Your
Grace the character and Essence embodies
what I love so much about this universe
which is the political manipulation that
he channels really well episode 9 where
he's ruling with an Iron Fist and making
people change allegiances was extremely
chilling and I can't wait to see more of
that in the next season for an era I'd
say I like the younger actors a bit more
and not saying that Emma DRC was bad by
any means and she did a great job in
showing a more mature version of
rhaenyra but the emotional depths that
Millie goes to for young greniera was
astounding any scene when she's
exploring the hardships of growing up
and dealing with that immense conflict
of responsibility was engrossing I love
how she'll go through a journey in each
episode and then arrives in a major
confrontation that severely changes her
as a character and thus normally shared
between her and viserys and their scenes
together were so precious such a good
actor and I'm excited to see her career
take off from here for Allison's I liked
both actresses pretty equally I think
Emily Kerry was a bit more reserved in
terms of breaking getting upset and
holding everything in which she did
perfectly meanwhile Olivia on the other
hand was really good at unleashing those
emotions and exploding the scene within
episode 7 where she rushes her near with
a blade was an amazing showcase for her
and she's just so goddamn expressive
with her eyes then I really like how
they made Allison have a strong moral
conscience in comparison to Otto it kind
of gives you someone to root for on the
green side of the coin it allows you to
sympathize with them some people may
prefer the more bold and evil villains
like Joffrey and Ramsay but having a
villain who isn't entirely bad and is
more self-serving is refreshing that's
why I think Tywin is the best villain in
Game of Thrones because he's a good guy
at the center of his story but he does
terrible things and the same can be said
for the high Towers technically what
they are doing is wrong since they are
defying viserys's wishes but it's
realistic to try to seize the power for
themselves along with the fact that
having a male ruler is probably more
supported by the common people so I
really enjoyed the civil War style
conflict in which you have characters on
either side that you can agree with
although the blacks are much more
portrayed as the good guys here we'll
see if that remains to be the case since
Rainer will probably do some heinous
things next season from how mad she was
in the ending scene one major aspect of
House of the dragon that is a
significant Step Up Above Game of
Thrones is the increased production
value the cinematography music set
pieces locations and VFX were all
expertly done and since they had such a
high budget to pump up these production
pillars the show was able to flourish
the cinematography in particular was
very different in comparison to Game of
Thrones and so much to the point that it
was kind of jarring at first because the
first few seasons of got feel more
grounded and naturalistic in their
approach while here the lighting in
particular feels more cinematic so many
scenes had Stark contrasts that made
them feel moodier and more dramatic
along with their overall color grade
playing into that feeling also I think
there are more impressive shots like
anything within the stepstones was the
delicious how they accentuated key
character moments more usage of shallow
Focus to bring out depth and more
Dynamic shots like rack focusing between
two different characters every scene is
uplifted by this great cinematography it
makes it feel like you're actually
watching something that's expensive for
locations initially I thought they were
going to overly rely on the volume to
film scenes but they actually went to
some beautiful places for example
locations where Dragonstone were
basically filmed on a mountain it was so
hard to film there that they had to
helicopter and equipment and set up tons
of infrastructure the result from all
this work pays off because it flushes
out the world when you can realistically
film in it instead of Faking it in the
volume not to say that the volume is bad
but overly relying on it can hurt the
skill of your show however when they do
use it like the confrontation scenes
outside of Dragonstone it's seamless
because it fits into the already large
collection of relocations that's a great
way to make these fictional places feel
real since the craters had a bigger
budget it it just feels so liberating
for them to fully spend it and not hold
back on where they wanted to film like
these large speeches during low tide in
which the crew only had a small window
of time to film was probably pretty
expensive to shoot at but it pays off
because the footage they managed to
capture was gorgeous then for the sets
they did not hold back at all and they
basically made the entirety of the
fictional locations they sought to
create the red keep is just one big set
with a bunch of connecting rooms and
Dragonstone is Grandeur on top of having
a much better atmosphere the steam
permeating from the ground and even the
war table glowing up were such nice
touches that weren't in Game of Thrones
it's also more logical to spare no
expense on these sets because of how
many scenes take place here it allows
the filmmakers to have a lot more
versatility Within These scenes when
they're able to shoot in almost any
direction like my favorite showcase was
during The Wonder of Vernier walking
with her baby to Queen Allison's and
they essentially walk through the entire
set showing off its pure scale I truly
wasn't disappointed it by any set piece
in the show and even the VFX was
outstanding it's nice that HBO had a lot
of practice doing Dragons because they
look fantastic in the show primarily due
to the fact that they have different and
distinct designs and don't look like
carbon copies of one another anymore
this also allows each of the dragons to
strap a certain personality like the
scaring unsettling way corrects these
noodles around his neck or granny vegar
slowly moving around given how massive
she is which they also did a good job in
communicating the skill of the dragons
like eamon's having to climb up vegar
like she was a tower or whenever they
positioned a dragon near one of our main
characters as a size comparison they do
not shy away from showing off their
dragons and that's also a refreshing
aspect because you can fully see them in
any night scene generally when VFX is
done at night it's always intentionally
done to hide the VFX but during vegar's
2 flight scenes you can clearly see
what's going on and since they don't
hide anything it makes for some insanely
good scenes veigar's last scene in the
finale because of this was easily one of
the best from how terrifying and scary
it was truly a very immersive experience
then that's just the visual side of
things because Ramin jawadi is back for
the score the man is still killing it
and the new themes he created for the
Valerian zornera were so good the chorus
chance of our nearest theme immediately
gives you this uplifted feeling that is
so addictive to listen to I also love
how it all culminates in her ending
scene when she becomes Queen in the
track called the crown of jaharis I
definitely recommend checking it out
along with the power of Prophecy then
the valerion theme sounds so unique with
its tribal-like Woodwinds playing with
drums and violins accompanying it it's
so fresh and distinct that it makes me
crave to see where mean jawadi flex and
experiment more within Westeros and
since we are on the subject of themes
it's kind of disappointing that there
wasn't a new main theme for House of the
dragon and they instead of used the one
from Game of Thrones it would make the
most sense to me to combine the themes
of near and House Targaryen for the
title sequence but oh well I think this
sets more of a lazy precedence for other
spin-off shows that are in development
and hope they don't follow down the same
path because it would be weird to hear
the same Game of Thrones theme in every
single show especially since the
upcoming sea snakes show as an example
already has such a cool theme but yeah
since the budget for House of the Dragon
is so big the production value of this
season is able to ascend and the result
is truly amazing so after going through
all of these scintillating positives
let's talk about some of the negatives
that bring the show down a little bit
starting with the pace at which the
story moves not in the sense of how
quickly each scene plays out because if
anything the writers take their time on
a scene to scene basis but more of the
fact of how fast time moves between
episodes AKA time jumps now it's really
hard to avoid this fact given that the
writers have to cover about 20 to 30
years of time within 10 episodes
personally I think it would have made
more sense to do a longer season so they
didn't have to skip so much time and
avoid that jarring feeling of having to
restart the show again I think Lancel
needs to get the shore Runners the
season stretcher because the main issue
with doing these time jumps is firstly
you are skipping over a lot of plot
lines my biggest gripe is getting thrown
into these developments at the mid
endpoint and we didn't get any build up
for them the worst examples of this is
her Harwin Strong's relationship with
rhaenyra and Damon's relationship with
Lena valerion within episode 6 both sir
Harwin and Elena die and you don't feel
that sad for them because there was no
time to build an emotional attachment to
these characters the whole point of
build up is to make us care about them
and understand who they are so when he
don't include it and throw their death
at us suddenly then we're going to feel
detached and the death has a soft impact
that and it's also just confusing to see
a character go from killing their wife
to them being in a family with a bunch
of kids in the next episode so having to
essentially re-meet these characters and
have to be introduced to what is
happening again shouldn't be the aim of
the writers and instead naturally get to
that point by taking more time to tell
your story then there's also the aspect
of how old the actors look now to me I
don't really care about this aspect that
much but it does become visually
confusing when someone like Kristen Cole
doesn't age at all within the 20 plus
years the show takes place in comparison
to other characters who age a lot like
hell the character Eamonn gets born in
between episodes five and six and he
looks just as old and if not older than
Kristin Cole by episode 8. So to that
degree it feels a bit inconsistent in
terms of how they age up the actors but
you kind of just have to accept that
aspect of the show because the only
option they have is to constantly keep
changing to older actors or use makeup
which using makeup I don't think would
really work so to change the actors
every 10 years within the show would be
even more jarring than just having the
same one to me the fans were already
losing their minds when they swapped out
Millie and Emily for their older
counterparts so doing that more
frequently I think would be much more
annoying so I think this just comes down
to people having to accept that part of
the show since there isn't a better
alternative to take for the last flaw of
the Season there are a couple of big
changes the writers make within the
story that I think needed to be
Rewritten or needed some time to breathe
the first example of this is Kristen
Cole's snapping and killing Joffrey the
reason why this development doesn't work
well is that they immediately do a
massive time Jump after it happens so
any big questions relating to this event
are instantly disregarded and aren't
addressed again like will there be any
repercussions for Kristen Cole doing
this does Allison defend him from being
kicked out of the kingsguard does
Kristen lie about the event and even if
he does wouldn't that further taint his
honor that he cares about and do any of
the witnesses care to make a statement
it just doesn't make sense to hit the
skip button right when we get to the
peak of Kristen's Arc there are so many
aspects surrounding this major story
development that need to be resolved and
the fact that the writers do a Time jump
over all of it is insane to me this kind
of ties back to the repercussions of
Doing Time jumps but I also think this
was a sloppily written scene because
there are some contrivances within this
scene like the crowd randomly turning
into a mosh bit for no reason other than
to forcibly instill a moment of
confusion and chaos
going into another big change they made
that I feel like needed to be reworked
we have rainey's busting through the
floor of aegon's Coronation and letting
the greens live in the book she wasn't
even in King's Landing when this all
went down and the writers made this
change to quote-unquote give rainey's a
bigger moment to shine which firstly
that doesn't really track well because
rainy's here is killing hundreds of
bystanders so this immediately
deteriorates my view of her since she
probably could have taken another exit
within the caves then secondly you are
basically asking the audience to get
annoyed when a character has the option
to eliminate the entire threat of the
show but chooses not to now I do agree
with the character decision here for
rhaenys however I feel like the writers
should have made her choice more
ambiguous by establishing an external
conflict that forces rhaenys out of the
scene like another Dragon showing up
from the pits or arches being posted up
about the shooter with these misfires of
endings it hurts an already good episode
and makes them end with a whimper in the
grand scheme of thing this isn't a major
seasonal issue but it does impact two
episodes so yeah going into house of the
Dragon I was not expecting the show to
be this good given that Ryan Connell
didn't have an impressive slate of past
work and the source material offered
little to no dialogue to work off of so
the fact that they were able to make a
season this great really blows me away
I'm immensely looking forward to season
two and since this story will most
likely be more consistently riveting
than the season on a story basis I'm
very excited thank you for watching and
if you're at all curious as to what I
think about other popular movies then I
probably rated them on letterboxed I
generally don't have enough time to make
videos on everything I watch so if
you're curious you can follow me on
there and see what I'm watching
currently I haven't really put any
attention on this so yeah the link will
be in the description and thank you in
advance if you follow me on there
foreign